[Narrator] So here's a pictorial representation of a parse tree for HTML.
Remember that all parse trees always grow upside down,
and we have our actual tokens at the leaves at the bottom
because this is a web page that just says, "Hello friends," with no tags,
and it has a large number of intermittent nodes corresponding to non-terminals
or rewrite rules in our grammar.
We want to walk over this parse tree and decide based on all these intermediate nodes
to print out to display on the screen as our web page Hello Friends.
That process is known as interpreting.
Walking over the tree to figure out what to do, and in some sense
it's just like interpreting a sentence in English to figure out what it means
or even translating a sentence from one language to another.
Recall that our 2 major elements in our syntax tree are represented in python as tuples.
Word elements just have 2 parts, the word word-hyphen element so that we know what's going on,
and then the actual text from the user, and tag elements which start with tag elements.
Again, to make it easier for us to interpret, we'll see that in just a minute.
The beginning tag, the ending tag, and then down here a list of other elements.
We also have a Java script element, which I haven't spent as much time talking about,
but is our way of representing embedded Java script pieces of code in a web page.
We're going to focus on these 2 for now.